initial results of antibody testing in  southern nevada showed that developing  herd immunity is not likely to happen  anytime soon  e7 health began testing for coronavirus  antibodies in may  now the study involved 1500 people who  thought they were exposed to the virus  or  had an upper respiratory infection of  those people  less than three percent had antibodies  so only three percent of that group had  the virus  dr jonathan bechtari says that means we  are far from herd immunity  for people who were hoping we would  achieve herd immunity which is sort of  immunity for the whole population once  enough people get it  through active infection that would  involve at least  50 to 60 to 70 percent of the population  being infected  before the whole population was  essentially  protected and we are long way from that  dr bhaktari says e-7 health  plans to launch at-home kobit 19 saliva  test  as early as next week